من المستحيل عدم ملاحظة أن العديد
من المركبات الروسية التي تغزو أوكرانيا
تحمل علامة مميزة
شاحنات الدبابات التي تقاتل
المركبات الهندسية واللوجستية وهي تتقدم
عبر أوكرانيا بالحرف Z
المطلي بشكل واضح باللون
الأبيض الذي لاحظه الأشخاص الذين تعرضوا للغزو
هنا في مدينة
كوبيانسك بشرق أوكرانيا.  حشد غاضب يحتشد بعد
ويهاجم مركبة واحدة ، وهو
علاقته الوحيدة الواضحة
بالحرب ، الحرف z
، يكاد يكون من المؤكد نوعًا من
التجميع التكتيكي ، هناك مليون
نظرية مختلفة حول ما تعنيه z ،
لكنني أعتقد أنها مجرد علامة
يسهل القيام بها بسهولة  شيء للاحتفال به تمامًا
مثل مثلث مربع في حرب حيث
لا يرفع الغزاة
المتمنيون علمهم الوطني ، اكتسبت شخصية واحدة أهمية خاصة في حدث كأس العالم للجمباز الأخير في الجمباز ، قبل المنافس الروسي إيفان كولياك البالغ من العمر 20 عامًا ميداليته البرونزية التي
يرتديها بشكل بارز من الألف إلى الياء  على صدره
كان يقف بجانب الرياضي الأوكراني
سبور  وصفته هيئة إدارة ts بأنه
سلوك صادم ،
لكن كيف تصف هؤلاء
الأطفال المصابين بأمراض مميتة ومقدمي الرعاية لهم
شكلوا z عملاقًا خارج دار
العجزة في مدينة قازان الروسية ، إنه لأمر
مثير للاشمئزاز أن الدولة تختار
الأطفال الصغار ليكونوا
آليات دعاية لهم  تكون الحرب خطيرة
عندما تصبح الرموز الصغيرة الصغيرة وكلاء
لكونها مواطنًا مخلصًا في
نظام استبدادي خلال وقت
الحرب لأن أولئك الذين لا يرتدونها
والذين لا يظهرون قد يكونون
مستهدفين من قبل
الدولة وفي هذا بشدة  أنتج
فيديو دعائي رجال روس يرتدون تلك الرسالة
يعلنون دعمهم للغزو
وهم يهتفون
لروسيا
لرئيس روسيا لبوتين.تظهر لقطة جوية
عملاقة مصنوعة من البرتقالي
والأسود لشريط سانت جورج وهو
رمز تقليدي للمجد العسكري الروسي
عادة  المرتبط بالنصر
على النازي
عن طريق الصدفة أو تصميم شخصية
لا تظهر في الأبجدية الروسية
أصبح رمزًا مبدعًا للوضع  إن في
غزو والحملة الدعائية
لكسب التأييد بين شعبه
فيل بلاك سي إن لندن